disclaimer die daten und zahlen in
diesem video entstammen
selbstverständlich keine offiziellen
steuerklärung und enthalten einige
lücken und kleinere macken wie vor euch
jedoch irrelevant sein sollten solange
er nicht finanzamt heißt in diesem fall
bekommt ihr natürlich pünktlich eine
perfekte steuererklärung mit schleife
von meinen steuerberater solange er mich
abonniert und die glocke aktiviert habt
versteht sie nicht
dieses video wird unterstützt von
kräften herzlich willkommen zu diesem
ersten alljährlichen connery jahres
finanz rückblick ich denke hier als
zuschauer die man im team und mir das
hier alles ermöglichen habt vollste
transparenz verdient und deswegen lasse
ich heute die hüllen fallen mit meinem
video 50.000 euro im monat durch youtube
habe ich vor ungefähr einem halben jahr
schon einige von euch schockiert aber
heute wird sich zeigen mädchen unser
umsatz im ganzen jahr so geschlagen hat
kommt mit auf eine wunderbare reise
durch das jahr 2020 wir werden uns alle
meiner projekte und einkommensquellen
anhand von graphen anschauen und
analysieren wie sie über sie hinweg
gestiegen oder gefallen sind in der
reihenfolge twitch meiner davos gelb
amazon affiliate mainz weit kann ahlm
ein schnittkurs mein hauptkanal und
kooperationen mit firmen und am ende
noch mal das spannendste eine zeitleiste
in der wir diese einnahmen mit meinen
ausgaben gegenüber stellen die dieses
jahr echt enorm waren
[Musik]
daraus wird sich dann auch von monat zu
monat mein persönliches bruttoeinkommen
errechnen und auch mal zu erwarten dass
privates nettoeinkommen werden wir euch
nicht vorenthalten in diesem ersten
regen jahres finanz rückblick
während wir hier allerdings feiern war
das jahr 2020 für viele menschen leider
das schlimmste bisher unermessliches
leid in form von krankheit
arbeitslosigkeit und einsamkeit haben
dieses jahr leider bestimmt ich bin
wirklich kein fan davon leute dazu
aufzufordern an der hilfsorganisation zu
spenden das muss jeder für sich selbst
entscheiden aber nutzt das vielleicht
als denkanstoß dass man auch mit
sozialer distanzierung mit digitalen
brettspiel abend dann über disco oder
skype oder android telefon die
einsamkeit mit einander bekämpfen kann
und dass das gerade jetzt wo vielleicht
auch viele von ihren verwandten und
freunden diese einsamkeit an weihnachten
besonders zu spüren bekommt besonders
wichtig ist bevor im jahr 2021 diese
ganzen impfungen hoffentlich wieder für
mehr normalität zurück
wir reisen zurück in den januar
frisch angekommen im jahr 2020 wie auf
einer wolke getragen vom high-tech
anfang des jahres motivierter als
deutsche bei ihrer steuererklärung und
voller tatendrang
zusammen mit meinem freund sebastian
mittlerweile mein manager der im
november 2009 10 offiziell das team
getreten hat gab es noch eine menge zu
tun um heute da zu sein wo wir sind
mittlerweile zu neunt im team schon im
märz gesellte sich barney zonen zum
freiberuflich die hauptkanal videos zu
schneit im juni kam florian und paul
dazu um sich freiberuflich um den
schnitt der zweite kanal videos zu
kümmern im selben monat geändert als
minijobber an und programmiert seitdem
an deinen speck nur einen monat darauf
hat er nils seinen kussa als grafiker
auf minijob basis zu dem skateboard
geholt womit wir also offiziell den
status der vetternwirtschaft erlangt
haben im september betrat alexis team
als mein erster vollzeit angestellter
und programmiert ebenfalls an meiner app
dani sich dazu entschieden hat lieber in
seiner heimat zu bleiben vollsten
respekt dafür mussten wir uns erneut auf
die suche nach einem hauptkanal katzer
machen und ins finale kamen felix und
alle und ja kurz gesagt ich habe beide
eingestellt felix als hauptkanal katar
in der oktober und alle vier
organisation schnitt und fotografie erst
vor kurzem anfang dezember für unsere
nati mensch felix knoke bin ich nur
einer von vielen auftraggebern aber der
gehört ja auch dazu seitdem er vor allem
jahr dem tory rpg minecraft server
projekt beigetreten ist welches aus
extrem vielen hammer menschen besteht
die aktuell noch etwas unter dem radar
etwas großes auf die beine stellen und
auch wenn davon jetzt nicht jeder hier
vollzeit im team arbeitet und manche
noch nebenbei aufträge ausführen ist
schon ziemlich krass so viele
arbeitsplätze schaffen zu haben mit dem
was
vor zehn jahren in meinem kinderzimmer
als luftschloss angefangen hat als
riesen luftschloss
aber das alles hier und auch das
equipment muss ich natürlich irgendwie
finanzieren und da jetzt geht es wieder
zurück zum januar 2020 mit der screening
plattform twitter
der januar war noch gar nicht so
spannend mit null euro
erst im februar ging es dann ein
bisschen hoch aber richtig nach oben
schoss ist im juni wo ich auch ein
selbstexperiment gemacht habe indem ich
eine woche lang jeden tag fast acht
stunden gestreamt oder an streamen
gearbeitet haben das gleiche verhalten
sind wir auch bei den trips werbungen
und diskutiert werden können und jetzt
etwas was ich sehr häufig gefragt wurde
wie hoch man die einnahmen meiner f
daraus geld bisher und da kommen jetzt
einmal die in-app-käufe davon hinzu die
im besten monat knapp über 600 euro
lagen und darauf kommen dann noch mal
die damals gewerbe einer menschen die
ihr euch dort ausschließlich freiwillig
anschauen könnt um zum beispiel eure
belohnungen zu verdoppeln ganz spannend
finde ich jetzt übrigens dieses kleine
tortendiagramm an dem wir noch mal
richtig gut aufgeschlossen sieht was für
wie viel prozent des umsatzes bisher
verantwortlich ist die nächste
einkommensquelle ist amazon erst in
meiner video beschreibung habe ich ja
immer mein equipment verlinkt und das
funktioniert so wenn ihr über so einen
link etwas kauft damit komme ich da von
den kleinen prozentsatz der zeit dafür
natürlich nicht mehr aber amazon gibt
die eben etwas ab und auch das war
natürlich wie die anderen sachen extrem
und hatte hier zuletzt im oktober eine
echt starke bank mit über 700 euro in
dem monat wirklich spannend werden tut
allerdings jetzt mit meinen zwei kanal
das hat im ersten halbjahr ganz und gar
nicht angefangen aber spätestens als es
im juni und juli flow und paul ins boot
geholt habt ist es richtig nach oben
gegangen und jetzt halt nur wenn wir
ungefähr bin ich auf meinen zweiten
kanal auch day youtuber was sich
natürlich auch an erwachsene gerade des
kanals aber natürlich auch an dem
einkommen widerspiegelt das natürlich
hier explodiert ist und alles andere in
den schatten stellt hierbei in orange
handelt sich übrigens um die
werbeeinnahmen von meinem zweiten kanal
die ich auch nur mal so am rande jetzt
für den dezember
hochgerechnet haben anhand der einnahmen
die bisher schon generiert wurden im
netz noch weiter geht es mit einem
schnittkurs da sieht die entwicklung ein
bisschen anders aus zwar nach der bei
der torte ansicht hier auch fast 75
prozent stellt damit wieder alles andere
in den schatten jedoch geht natürlich
der trend klar nach unten so war es
anfang des jahres im schnitt ungefähr
bei fünf bis sechstausend euro im monat
was wirklich heftig ist das eben sehr
passives einkommen ist nichtsdestotrotz
mache ich sehr sehr selten dafür werbung
und mittlerweile haben wir natürlich
auch stufen über 1000 leute was wirklich
krasses der schnittkurs war gerade ende
2019 und an
2020 echt ein richtig gutes gefühl ich
habe so viel arbeit reingesteckt in ein
produkt mit denen ihr quasi schneiden
lernen können möglichst effizient und
dass das dann auch wirklich leute
einfach gekauft haben uns mal richtig
viele und ich davon haben wir so eine
sicherheit auch neben meinen normalen
youtube werbeeinnahmen hat das ist schon
wirklich unfassbar verrücktes gefühl und
auch zu den normalen die werbeeinnahmen
von meinem hauptkanal komme jetzt ihr
einmal in rot eingezeichnet von anfang
des jahres ungefähr 6000 euro im schnitt
jetzt hochgeschossen auf ungefähr 10.000
schnitt das liegt hauptsächlich
natürlich daran dass die cpm also das
geld das man quasi also ich überblick
bekommt gegen ende des jahres natürlich
komplett hoch schießt im detail sieht er
dass man hier einmal den grünen weil man
dem hauptkanal wie sich die cpm
verändert hat nun einmal in blau wie
sich die cpm eine 2 kanal von januar bis
dezember entwickelt hat und daran liegt
es dann auch dass man hauptkanal auch
wenn die klicks etwas zurückgegangen
sind tatsächlich nicht immer lukrativer
wurde aber auch das wird sich natürlich
im januar ein bisschen entspannt zusehen
wie die hier das tortendiagramm das
meiste machen natürlich die youtube
werbeeinnahmen bisher aus im vergleich
dazu ist mein schnittkurs aber auf jeden
fall recht deutlich und weil zum
beispiel im märz sogar ein gutes stück
profitabler als man hauptkanal was
werbeeinnahmen angeht jetzt im dezember
der aber wie gesagt auf hochrechnungen
basierten sieht man auch deutlich dass
mein zweiter kanal über die hälfte der
einnahmen eines hauptkanals markt und
das mit nur zehn prozent der abonnenten
aber natürlich dafür sieben mal so
häufigen applaus und zu allen möglichen
themen zum beispiel wie genau ich
investiere was gerade aktuell mit meiner
app downloads geld passiert und zum
beispiel auch dieses video in dem ich
einmal drei stunden gar nichts nach aber
auch wenn dieses tortendiagramm
natürlich schon krass ist werde ich das
jetzt auch noch mal schlagartig
verändern mit unserer letzten
einnahmequelle und zwar in kooperation
die stellen tatsächlich was die
garantiesumme angeht wirklich noch mal
alles in den schatten und machen 75
prozent unseres gesamtumsatzes aus was
schon wirklich wert ist und das sind
auch natürlich so wie jetzt mittlerweile
in schwindelerregenden höhen sind
alleine durch werbeeinnahmen jetzt eben
oktober und dezember über 70.000 euro
umsatz erwirtschaftet ja also einmal
verrückt ist aber verrückt und da bin
ich auch sehr dankbar wenn sie das
gleich an die ausgaben geht die ich für
equipment und personal habt werdet schon
sehen dass man da sonst deutlich kürzer
treten ist dass wir da aber nicht
deutlich kürzer treten müssen haben wir
an werbepartnern zu verdanken wie zum
beispiel pokémon in diesem monat
natürlich auch säfte ist unsere
buchhaltung software und setzt schon
seit 2009 10 unterstützt auch hier
wieder in diesem video aber dazu kann
man später wir kommen jetzt erst mal zu
den ausgaben weil die haben es wirklich
in sich angefangen mit sonstigen
ausgaben das ist alles außer
personalkosten also kameras
lampentechnik laptops computer nicht nur
für mich sondern auch zb für ihn hier
aber auch natürlich fahrtkosten und zum
beispiel räumlichkeiten und haben wir
hoffentlich steile zunahme zb oktober da
kannte das ganze wirklich kaum grenzen
fast 10.000 euro in dem zeitraum zum
beispiel war sein laptop da sein monitor
dann hier ein fernseher natürlich noch
viel mehr
während im mai zum beispiel das ganze
relativ sparsam war mit nur knapp 1500
euro
das klingt natürlich viel aber nur nicht
diese investments können wir unsere
videos so gestalten wie wir es gerne
hätten so eine hohe qualität produzieren
und in diesem sind natürlich auch
dadurch so viel geld verdienen ein
weiteres extrem wichtiges und auch
größeres investment sind da die
personalkosten die deutlich höher noch
mal sind natürlich im januar bei 0 euro
bei 1 das team natürlich erstmal sich
aufgebaut hat und wurde logischerweise
auch mit jedem mitarbeiter immer ein
stückchen höher dass das hier jetzt so
variiert liegt natürlich daran dass ich
in manchen monaten vielleicht ein
bisschen mehr videos von dem kater
gebraucht habe dass in dem einen monat
vielleicht noch mal ein extra kameramann
führend was gebraucht habe und natürlich
auch daran dass manager prozentual
beteiligt ist und kein festes gehalt hat
dass man immer gleich bleibt alles in
allem bringt uns das auf einen unglauben
jahresumsatz von 600 4486 euro und die
traun 80 cent das blickte sich einmal
auf in 213.000 euro also ungefähr 35,3
prozent ausgaben und eine gewinnmarge
von 46,7 prozent also 390.000 euro die
man mehr oder weniger als mein
persönliches bruttoeinkommen beschenken
wer dieses video gesehen hat der weiß
dass ich mir monatlich für meine
privaten ausgaben nur circa 3000 euro
überweise ich versuche also eigentlich
so zu leben als würde ich nur
viereinhalb tausend euro brutto im monat
verdient und ignoriert die 32.500 die
ich wirklich im schnitt verdient das
kommt dann alles auch sparbuch
beziehungsweise auf ein aktiendepot
damit ich im alter abgesichert wenn aber
auch vielleicht schon ziemlich früh
finanziell unabhängig sein kann aber
moment da steht jetzt knapp 390.000
weil sie ein bruttoeinkommen aber klar
dagegen natürlich noch mal sachen weg
und 2d code einkommensteuer soll ich mit
regen kann man völlig zu recht den
steuer höchstsatz erwarten und auf alles
über 250.000 euro jahreseinkommen sogar
45% reichensteuer wie viel das jetzt
genau für mich ist weiß ich erst nachdem
mein steuerberater hat die
steuererklärung fertig haben wenn ich
das ganze jetzt aber mal in einem brutto
netto rechner eingeben
wer sich zwar ein bisschen anders
verhält als ein spezialfall jetzt aber
für unsere zwecke auf jeden fall
ausreichend ist ja dann wird mir hier
angezeigt dass ich netto davon 215 1200
euro über habe nachdem ich ein
solidaritätszuschlag von circa 8400 euro
zahle 04 kirchensteuer einer lohnsteuer
von 153 1300 euro und natürlich auch
sozialabgaben in höhe von 13.900 euro
zahlen da ich selbstständig bin wird das
für ein spezialfall noch ein stückchen
anders sein jeder aber erfahrungsgemäß
eine relativ gute richtung das waren
alles keine komplett finalen zahlen
einige sachen wären wenn man das in der
offiziellen steuererklärung machen
würdet ihr komplizierter ist dieses
video zu lassen würde also nehmt alle
zahlen bitte neues gruppe schätzung und
ohne gewähr
und haben noch mal vielen dank ich denke
ich dass im namen des ganzen teams sagen
aber das ist echt
natürlich auch für mich klar aber auch
was ja alle ja man kann das ist und
schon echten es recht ist aber echt das
thema steuern haben wir ja schon mal
angesprochen und sagen das ist spaß
machen tut das nicht und dann dauert
auch noch immer viel zu lang saß der als
sponsor des heutigen videos der diesen
kanal schon seit über einem jahr
unterstützt ist ein extrem smartes und
preiswertes tool das einen diese last
ordentlich abnimmt ich muss gar nicht
erklären die hessen gesetzt seine
steuern auf herkömmliche art und weise
zu machen dass bisher alle schon wenn
ihr sowas schon mal gemacht habe aber
ich kann nicht sagen wie sie das mit
hefter skills man nimmt ein beleg und
scannt ihn einfach per app ein wenn man
eine pdf datei einfach per drag drop in
die software selbst erkennt dann
automatisch die rechnungsnummer den
rechnungssteller und den rechnungsbetrag
dann auch ebene kategorie angeben und
man hat innerhalb von sekunden ohne viel
kopfschmerzen an der hammer ordnung mit
wertvollen statistiken und sogar live
einnahmen überschuss rechnung dass
selbst das ganz 14 tagen ein kostenlos
ohne zahlungsinformationen angeben zu
müssen über den link in einem video
beschreibung und spart mit dem kot tommy
4 m 50 prozent auf eure ersten vier
monate verabschiedet euch 2021 von
papierkram stress und das für weniger
geld als ihr wahrscheinlich und ich mit
sicherheit für streaming dienste ausgeht
absetzen mit diesen worten wünschen wir
euch jetzt ein frohes fest verbringt
viel zeit mit eurer familie können
kommt gut ins hoffentlich nicht ganz so
apokalyptisch im jahr 2021 wir sehen uns
im nächsten video und zwar ist man im
letzten von 2020 an dem ich mich noch
mal mit einem knall ins nächste jahr
verabschieden werde also abonniert gern
diesen kanal und dann sehen wir zunächst
mal wieder ganz gut
[Musik]